my god it's beautiful
whoa easy now naruto
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my full rick and morty season 5
episode 7 video there were a whole bunch
of anime references a whole bunch of
callbacks to previous episodes including
a giant
literal and metaphorical call back to
earlier in season five
so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes
i'm also doing a rick and morty merch
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
easter egg from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet we'll just start
with wtf moments and easter eggs the
beginning of the episode and work our
way through shot by shot and i'll just
number these as we go along to stay
organized
starting with the title of the episode
gotron jerry siss
rick van gaalion a reference to voltron
and neon genesis evangelion you could
also call this episode the one with the
giant space baby for the giant twin cess
baby from earlier this season
they also heavily parodied a lot of the
plot of famous mob movies like
goodfellas and scarface
and i also love that they named the
giant space baby naruto
that's canon now and the baby is still
alive at the end of the episode so it's
still floating around in outer space out
there somewhere
but the opening scene is them actually
paying off a reference from way back
during season 4 with boob world
back during season 4 episode 5 the
terminator snakes episode
at the end of the episode rick says that
their adventure
during that week counted as one of
morty's 10 free adventures
rips up his adventure card which itself
was a call back to season 3 with the
adventure card itself
and morty complains about having wanted
to go to boob world rick saying that he
can't now
but then turns to offer summer a trip to
boob world and she says maybe later
cut to later we're in season five now
and they're actually doing it
they're seeing the lyrics to the song
the lyrics themselves are a joke about
boob world basically being two worlds
because it's a pair of boobs
they've got special hats on they
actually had darren chris back i believe
he was the yellow gotron pilot at the
end of the episode
but he also sang the boob world theme
song over the end credits too that's
darren chris
[Music]
it's actually singing but then rick
reveals the only reason why summer
actually got invited is because blue
world had all these problems with
anti-sexism protests for the past 30
years
and they've just rebranded as a boob
quote-unquote empowerment experience and
if they bring a woman they get in for
free
and the reference to the coke can in six
flags is actually a thing in real life i
actually grew up in the midwest near
six flags nowadays you can still get a
discount on your passes by bringing
empty coke cans
but the discount used to be way bigger
back in the day summer invents a new
word just combining a couple different
words for excited stoked in sight
which they pay off in the next scene
after she replaces morty as rick's
number two with morty trying to invent a
word to seem cool too
but then rick spots the last remaining
gotron ferret that he's been trying to
collect for a long time and that sets
off the actual plot of the episode
the gotron ferrets being their version
of the voltron lions
he yanks out the previous dead pilot
skeletons still in its uniform
throws it out sort of setting up the
twist later in the episode where they go
around
either killing or just stealing the
other robots they set up the whole
subplot with the dueling internal
monologues it's basically a big play on
ray liotta's internal monologues from
the goodfellas movie
because a lot of the later jokes do
parody the goodfellas movie
in summer's internal monologue basically
starts stepping all over morty's
internal monologue
and later at the end of the episode they
also call that out too saying that they
were parasites the whole time
internal monologue parasites which
remind you of the season 2 total rickall
episode with the parasites that were
showing up in fake memories
picking up all kinds of random parasites
and their adventures all over the
universe
they have that funny spoilers joke when
morty tries to explain how they're all
going to combine
rick and some are just yelling spoilers
at him which you could also say wound up
being a very timely reference
as this whole episode basically leaked
out a couple weeks early and there were
spoilers everywhere so a lot of you
actually probably watched this episode a
couple weeks ago
they make another reference to gene
their neighbor who rick ran over
during the episode where morty and
summer's baby came from when the giant
sperm monsters were attacking everyone
on their street
there were a number of different
references to that earlier episode
setting up the big
twist later when the baby comes back
there were several parts during the
episode
where different characters in different
scenes basically recap the entire plot
of that earlier episode
remember the time with a giant baby that
got fired into outer space by the
government if you thought it was weird
how many times they referenced the plot
of that episode it was all just to
remind people i think because it's been
a couple weeks like hey remember the
time when we did this because it's going
to be a really big thing in a couple
minutes
beth literally calls the baby out right
after this saying that that was the end
of them getting really excited about
doing things as a family
then summer calls it out sarcastically
and references several other major wtf
plot twists
in the show's history like beth
wondering if she's a clone or not from
season three
we actually just saw space beth come
back at the beginning of season five
some are saying that she only exists
because they fail to abort her is a
callback to season one's
interdimensional cable episode
summer then also makes an anime
reference that's a deep cut reference
for the original anime series that
voltron was based on
voltron is just a westernized cartoon
version of the anime series beast king
go lion
they play another internal monologue
joke on morty and then they do their big
voltron montage of them zip-lining to
all the gotron ferrets
and each place that they go to just gets
like a little less
cool until you get to morty's which is
parked in an actual parking garage jerry
calling out how ridiculous some of it is
like why did i zipline all the way to
hawaii just to rendezvous above my house
in orbit
is them just joking about the logic of
the actual voltron series
rick integrates his portal gun
technology with the gotron ferrets to
open a portal to the nibble dug system
where they fight the first big alien
kaiju
and they basically play it as if rick is
trying to enact his adult fantasy like
he's an adult toy collector
collecting giant toys and he has this
very specific way that he wants this to
play out so he's waiting to reveal
all these things to the family but in
doing this he's also calling out a lot
of the tropes of a lot of these big mech
anime series fighting kaiju like first
you have to all fight it separately in a
really bad way so we get our asses
kicked
then we rally form the giant robot kick
its butt a little more
then also setting up another big twist
when he forms the energy sword from
voltron
so the making fun of anime tropes while
also making fun of a lot of adult toy
collectors
and rick just going crazy trying to
collect all these ferrets
a lot of times when they have jokes on
the series about rick being obsessed
with collecting toys like the nintendo
rant from a couple seasons ago
that's them actually making fun of
justin roiland most of the time because
he's such a huge toy collector in real
life if for example the nintendo rant
was something that justin roiland did
in real life he just came into the rick
and morty writers room one day
yelling about a scheme to make money on
nintendo ds collector editions
and they turned it into a bit during an
episode if you ever watch the behind the
scenes with justin with him in
interviews in his old house he also has
toys just stacked up
all over his house morty has another ray
leota goodfellow style internal
monologue teeing up the beginning of the
end like everything was awesome until
rick started to go off the rails as if
his internal monologue is speaking in
past
tense this whole time during the episode
they said that the whole multiverse
voltron twist rick calls a bunch of
alternate reality ricks and it goes
full good fellas but a lot of these
mobster parodies are parodies from
many different mob movies jerry reveals
that he was ready to blow
someone to avoid being kicked off the
team setting up the joke during the
episode of jerry being gay which they
pay off later with yo-yo rick
the band playing at their cookout is the
same ban from season 2 episode 10
at bird person's wedding morty gets
bummed out when he finds out that he's
the
only morty here who hasn't been to boob
world
all the different ricks here like i said
are parodies of different famous mob
movies
like there's the godfather version of
rick that they're calling big fat rick
ricardo montoya is a version of scarface
later in the episode they actually go
full scarface with the end of the
episode and the end of that movie
hothead rick is just a version of sunny
from the first godfather movie
and little ricky wrap it up is a version
of joe pesci's character from goodfellas
they make a joke about how they try to
create all these different characters
like they're all supposed to be very
different versions of rick yet they
somehow have the exact same size face
that's more of an animator joke than
anything else hot head rick makes
another reference to the giant space
baby like i said they referenced the
plot of that episode several times he
basically recaps the entire plot of that
episode
then when c137 rick says are we ever
going to live that down that's sort of a
meta reference the writers basically
saying
are we ever going to live down that
really wtf joke from that episode
like maybe giant space baby with morty
and summer was a little too far
the whole thing with the gotron ferret
blowing up in hot-headed rick's face i
think is just a reference to sunny
getting killed off during the godfather
something similar happens later in the
episode too where he gets lit on fire
like he has this gruesome
death in in the godfather movie sonny
dies a very gruesome death
they replace him with yo-yo rick they
also try to justify him with that meta
reference about how he's cool
despite being lame because he owns his
lameness there are several points in the
episode where it did feel like the
writers were making fun of themselves
for some lame jokes
they have that big good fellows montage
of them taking out a ton of competition
to go get everyone's gotron ferrets in
different universes killing people off
stealing them
you could call this a reference to
almost any mob movie montage
almost all the big famous mob movies
have montages like this before things go
off the rails
then summer's internal monologue
explains how rick's scheme works
they keep adding more and more gotron
ferrets so each combined group of five
also forms another giant gotron they
call the first one the go-go
tron later they make an even bigger one
too at the end of the episode
they go around to everyone's different
universe basically being unkillable
paying off rick's earlier reference
saying that they're literally too big to
fail
because the go-go tron the even bigger
version of the robot is literally bigger
than all the other kaiju they're
fighting
except for the giant space baby at the
end of the episode
the other parody song this week is all
about combining pasta with anime they
have the boob world theme song at the
end of the episode that darren chris
saying
this one during their montage is just
about pasta and anime because of the mob
movie parodies in the voltron
during this montage you notice some of
the kaiju kills are also parodies of
tropey
mob movie kills like a hundred giant
buckets of cement for the centipede
kaiju that they then drown
in the ocean then things start to go off
the rails the different ricks start to
argue with each other and they get rid
of yo-yo rick by blackmailing him
using a version of jerry it's another
version of jerry but it's then paying
off the jerry might be gay reference
from earlier in the episode saying that
he was ready to blow
someone summer takes his place you know
that now she's wearing a black lion suit
basically meaning that she took yoyo
rick's spot on the team
summer makes a borat movie reference
when she's dissing morty then rick
starts to go crazy summer explaining
that he's been snorting detergent and it
becomes the big scarface parody with
tony montana getting high
on his own supply like he taps his nose
and yells at summer to get him more
the whole bit with a nightclub and morty
being an associate security chief feels
like a casino movie parody with robert
de niro another solid mob movie
the dress that summer is wearing also
seems a little like the dress that
sharon stone wore
during the movie casino rick calls her a
queef summer just queefed in morty's
face a little while ago
rick then explains the even larger go go
gotron which is a hundred ferrets
combined
and morty gets captured by the anime
characters that they stole the ferris
from earlier
like i said i think the yellow one here
is voiced by darren chris
and because part of the title of the
episode is taken from evangelion
and this character is a red-headed anime
character who pilots a giant space robot
i'm assuming that this is meant to be a
parody of asuka langley from ava
probably the most famous red-headed
pilot in all of mecca anime
you notice that all the anime characters
are also animated as if they are anime
characters inside a rick and morty
episode with the stereotypical physical
traits
in expressions of anime characters
that's why they say that they're
literally
designed for piloting the robots because
they are anime characters
and they call what rick is doing
appropriation as in cultural
appropriation
they try to bribe morty with boob world
money and when morty drags himself back
there's a whole bunch of references here
in the graffiti
the wall reads get caponed which is a
reference to getting pwned
and al capone because of all the mob
jokes some of the graffiti reads gun
dumb
a play on the gundam franchise of the
big mega anime series
there's a bunch of other names here too
some of these names might be animators
who worked on the episode
hot-headed rick betrays the group like i
said he dies a gruesome death like sunny
died a gruesome death during the
godfather movie
jerry makes another joke about being gay
telling his story about traveling alone
on a flight to paris trying to get over
a breakup
you could also say that them kicking
morty off the team is a reference to
michael corleone pushing fredo aside
before he had him killed
rick betrays summer by replacing her
with the red-headed asuka langley parody
anime girl who tried to bribe morty
she's also reading a gun dumb magazine
which has an actual gundam on the cover
she says that she has a bunch of temps
lined up with previous robot experience
obviously that's a reference to the big
betrayal at the end of the episode
they have that brief bit about beth and
jerry being tainted by their time
working in the rick voltron mafia
wanting to have summer whacked
then wanting to kill themselves and wait
for her at the doors to hell so they can
kill her again
morty calls it out and then they turn on
a dime the minute she walks in crying
about being fired by rick
and she explains her secret history with
the space baby
which itself turns into a huge parody of
the movie arrival with amy adams which
is a great movie if you haven't seen it
they make an abortion joke while she's
teeing that up and the funny thing we
learn about this because this is all
canon now
is that the us government the president
has a secret military base on mars
so the president probably knew about
baby naruto this whole time
we find out the government wanted to use
him as a giant weapon but summer cared
about him helped him escape
then setting up the big reveal at the
end of the episode where they pilot it
like a giant kaiju alien
when they go back to raking the giant go
go go tron it's literally tony montana's
office from the end of the scarface
movie and they basically do the end of
the movie with him being betrayed and
all the other anime characters coming
for him
he does a parody of that famous line say
hello to my little me pulling out a
little rick-shaped gun
and morty and the rest of the family
swoop in on giant baby naruto
saving the day he's got a giant american
flag diaper his wristband reads weapon 1
the meta 8005 reference is just boobs
spelled backwards which is also a
callback to rick's secret code word from
earlier this season that he used to
control all the duplicate families
and it also reads made in las vegas
because that's where morty's sperm
fertilized summer's egg so the baby was
literally made in las vegas
the baby is super op and just completely
swathes the giant robot away they get
rid of the anime characters
then they explain at the end of the
episode that even though everything is
fine with the family again now
because they got rid of all the ferrets
now alien kaiju are coming to earth
unchallenged and millions of people
are already dead like it's no big deal
like they don't care about it at all
also trapping jerry outside raising the
blast shields on the house up
they've actually done that raised the
blast shields on the house almost in
every single episode during season five
then when morty and summer have that
final dueling internal monologue scene
wrapping up the episode they pay off the
parasites joke with rick shooting both
of them calling them voice ovarians
then rolling his eyes and gagging as if
it's him making fun of this
joke this whole bit with the voiceover
for being lame
i wouldn't call it a fourth wall break
but it is the writers basically calling
themselves out for doing a lame joke
then during the post-credits scene they
do a big twist on the whole kaiju trope
from anime series about how in anime
series
kaiju often come from other dimensions
or other worlds but in the rick and
morty multiverse they're secretly highly
intelligent creatures trying to help
humanity by giving them the cure for
aids
but in traveling through their
interdimensional portal they're stripped
of all their intelligence and clothes
making them seem like terrible monsters
and if you're paying attention to the
subtitles apparently the cure for aids
in the rick and morty multiverse is just
basically preserved lemons the recipe
that the kaiju tells them one part lemon
juice four part bay leaves
one pinch of sea salt is basically the
recipe you use for preserving lemons
but if you spotted any other big easter
eggs in the episode that i didn't talk
about during the video just write them
below in the comments
my full rick and morty season 5 episode
8 video will post next week just like
normal
marvel's what if episodes are also going
to start next week too i'll be doing
videos for all those episodes
just like rick and morty just like the
marvel loki episodes it will heavily
trade on the multiverse inside the mcu
make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss any of those episodes
i also just did a big venom 2 trailer
video you can click here to watch that
and you can click here for that brand
new marvel what if trailer in new
shangshi trailer video easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
you